>>Well, thank you very much, Dean Saloner.
As Garth said, I was with the advisory council several years
ago and got to know Garth very well.
And I can certainly attest to a great selection that was
made and Garth being the dean of our school.
Well, good afternoon, everyone.
It's a pleasure to be back here at my alma mater and the
GSB.
In fact, I was a member of the first graduating class, back
in 1967, when this building first opened as the brand new
Stanford Business School.
>>
[laughter]
And it really makes you feel old as you come back and see
that the new school is soon to be opened.
It is also ironic that early next year, as Garth mentioned,
just a few months from now, that I will retire from Wells
Fargo, 42 years after I first joined General Mills, having
just graduated from the GSB.
And again, as Garth mentioned ? and I hope that you all,
when you are contemplating your next career move, would stay
and be more flexible than I was.
Because it is true that, when I was thinking of what to do
upon graduation, I really did not know for sure what I
wanted to do, but I was very certain of what I did not want
to do.
I was certain that I did not want to ever work for a bank or
work in New York City.
>>
[laughter]
And a mere eight years later, I became an executive of
Citibank at 53rd and Park Avenue.
So keep an open mind.
>>
[laughter]
Since I have been around this business world a long time and
about ready to "hang it up," as we used to say on the
athletic field, what I thought I would do this afternoon is
share some thoughts with you entitled, "What have I learned
since business school?"
I hope this does not cause you to quit school and ask for a
tuition refund, however.
>>
[laughter]
As you will soon hear, I am quite passionate about certain
ideas that have worked for me over my business career and
have not usually been an important element of the curriculum
at leading graduate schools of business.
I began experimenting with these ideas shortly after my
first general management job in 1969 at General Mills, but I
did not put all of these ideas into an actual marketplace
test until I joined Norwest in Minneapolis back in 1986 as
vice-chairman, head of the banking group there.
Let me briefly summarize our results from 1986 to now.
Our assets have grown from 20 billion to 1.3 trillion, our
net income from a hundred million to an estimate of $12
billion this year that analysts are forecasting, our market
cap from 800 million to 135 billion, a compound rate of 25
percent.
We had 15,000 team members back then; we have 282,000 today.
We had 700 stores; today, we have 10,000.
We have also today ranked as the 14th most admired company
in the Fortune Magazine's Annual Survey and Bearn's magazine
in the United States.
And Bearn's magazine ranks as one of the top 25 most-
respected companies in the world.
Now, I mention these things only to demonstrate what I think
is the power of some of the things that I have learned since
business school.
And these quantitative and qualitative measurements at least
give an indication that there has been some value to those
ideas.
I would also ? I also want to mention that I?ve had the
privilege of meeting the faculty of this great school on
many occasions and in many different ways where I have
spoken about what I thought were important changes that
needed to be made in the curriculum of all business schools.
And I'm pleased to see that the changes that have been made
by the GSB in the last five or ten years were very
consistent with some of the thoughts and ideas I'll convey
to you today.
What I learned at the GSB and in my engineering courses, in
terms of quantitative methods and finance, accounting,
strategy, and marketing, were obviously of great value and
were very important, and I believe are very important to
business success.
But on the margin, they were not even in the same ballpark
and important as the concepts of leadership, people as a
competitive advantage, and what I would describe as "
management by culture."
But I am getting a little ahead of myself.
And I want to mention that I think one of the values of the
engineering background that I had, even though ? you should
all feel good that, those of you who cross bridges at least,
or work in tall skyscrapers ? that I was not a real engineer
as such.
I was an industrial engineer at Stanford, and industrial
engineering really was a quantitative application of
business principles.
In fact, many of the professors were in the both the
business school and the industrial engineering department.
And it was things like statistical analysis, quantitative
business methods, operations research, production
efficiency, computer science, and so on.
We all did take the same basic engineering courses of math,
physics, and so forth.
But while my liberal arts classmates were playing volleyball
in the afternoon, we engineers were in the lab doing work.
We were not on the baseball field, at least in my case.
And, although I never practiced as an engineer, I do think
that the engineering background did significantly influence
the process that I use in making decisions.
And that process does appear to be different from that of
some other large companies' CEOs.
My engineering background influenced my extensive of use of
deductive reasoning, the importance of analyzing data
intelligently, the ability to ask relevant questions to
challenge existing assumptions, and do sensitivity analysis
on the various alternatives that could be modeled on what
decision to make.
In short, to thoroughly understand the quantitative elements
and the risk vs. reward aspects of the ultimate decision.
But I also learned a lot outside the classroom, especially
on the athletic field and through actual business
experience, by making a lot of mistakes, but hopefully never
making the same mistake twice, ie. learning from one's
mistakes.
The most important things I have learned in my 42 years in
business and 34 years in financial services is that, success
in the business world ? especially in the world of financial
services or other service companies ? is less about brains
at the 99 percent level, and more about people development,
motivation, coaching, leadership, teamwork, integrity,
culture, community involvement, vision, values, and a broad
understanding of a variety of business disciplines,
especially interpersonal relations.
Intelligence above the 99 percent level might even be
inversely correlated with some of these attributes.
GMAT scores just don't measure these skills.
In today's business world, we need broad generals to
successfully run large and complex companies who desperately
need leaders.
This is where sports comes in, at least for me.
From the age of 4 through 21, I played some form of
competitive athletics for two to three hours almost every
day.
Sports helped me to understand human nature, teamwork, and
how emotions impact performance.
Sports helped me to appreciate the value of personal
discipline, physical conditioning, and the use of time.
But, perhaps most importantly, athletics introduced me to
the power of interpersonal dynamics.
I experience, as I know many of you have, that teamwork and
team spirit causes a group of individuals to perform well
above the level of their individual abilities.
In basketball, for instance, it's not the five best players
who become champions, it is the best five players who do so.
So what does it take to be successful in business?
Well, if I had to do it all over again, perhaps the MBA I
received is not the best degree to lead a company to
success, after all.
Perhaps you should seek four very different degrees.
First, get a degree in believing.
Believe in the enormous talent of people, people at all
levels of your organization.
To receive a degree in believing, your dissertation must
answer this question.
"Why do many people enter business being bright, well-
educated, energetic, wanting to make a difference, and in a
few years, feel bored, ignored, unfulfilled, and
unimportant? Why is that??
Today's MBAs need a second degree: in affirming.
They must affirm their belief that almost everyone in any
organization, profit or not-for-profit, wants to contribute,
wants to do a good job.
Receiving this degree requires that we treat everyone in our
organization with respect as equals, as talented people, as
important members of our team, working together toward a
common goal, regardless of rank, education level, or
compensation.
Third, I would recommend a master's degree in "M and F.?
That stands for "Motivation and Fun.?
Yes, you heard correctly: Fun.
I know it may be surprising to you, but even bankers should
have fun.
>>
[laughter]
I define "fun" as ?Working with people to help them get
excited about what they're doing, help create an enjoyable
work environment, have fun, and then recognize them publicly
with great fanfare for a job well-done.?
When people aren't having fun, when they're not recognized
for outstanding performance, when no one says thanks, they
do become disengaged and feel unimportant.
Recognition, I believe is, on the margin, more important
than salaries, benefits, and bonuses, because most all
companies pay competitively.
It is corporate America's most underutilized, motivational
tool.
Try thanking someone too much for a job well-done.
You can't do it.
So you need a master's degree in believing, affirming,
motivation, and fun.
And then, you need a doctorate, a doctorate in leadership,
the most advanced and important degree possible.
What is leadership?
There are probably as many definitions as there are leaders.
I'm sure many of you have your own.
I define leadership as the "Act of establishing and
communicating a vision of the future, and the art of
motivating others to align with and embrace that vision."
Leaders enable people to do such great things that they
believe that they can continue doing them.
Leaders take people from where they are to where they've
never been.
That's why leadership is the critical skill for sustainable
business success.
But great leaders give power to their teams; they do not
monopolize it.
You cannot share a vision unless you share the power to
achieve it.
Leaders don't point fingers, they point direction.
They show the way by personal example.
And I'm sure everyone here today is still familiar with
Maslow's Hierarchy of Needs, which I did learn in both my
engineering and MBA classes.
It arranges individual needs in a pyramid.
And, as you well know, safety is at the bottom moving up
through food, shelter, and at the top, a feeling of self-
worth.
In the same way, I believe there's a pyramid of tools to
lead any business to greatness.
Importantly, but at the bottom, there are the fundamentals
of the business enterprise: the accounting, the computer
literacy, quantitative skills.
You move up the pyramid to finance, manufacturing skills,
sales marketing, and then to the top, empowering people,
motivation, recognition, communication skills, and at the
apex, leadership.
The need for speed and adaptability in today's world leaves
zero room, in my opinion, for dictatorship, centralized
command and control, and in the worst sense of the word,
hierarchy.
Hierarchy assumes the higher up you are, the better you are
at making decisions.
Here's a secret: Almost every person at Wells Fargo knows
more about their specific work than I do: tellers,
assistance people, commercial bankers, store managers, you
name it.
They all know more about the needs of their customers.
Because they know more, there's no need to waste time coming
to me for a decision.
Make the decision yourself, and let me know what you've
decided.
If you think I can help you to make better decisions, I'm
available to do so.
I remember reading books in my MBA class that said, The
maximum number of people who should report to someone else
to have what was called ?effective control,? was six to
eight, but never more than ten.
Baloney!
It should be 15 to 20 at least, maybe even more.
The more people who report to you, the better.
It forces you to delegate, give responsibility, and not
interfere.
It allows others a satisfaction of running their own show
and being responsible for their own results.
It also reduces layers between you and the customer.
The truth is, I didn't run Wells Fargo.
We have nearly one hundred businesses, each with their own
fully-loaded profit and loss.
We are very decentralized.
The business heads are totally responsible for their
businesses.
They report to six group heads, who are the CEOs for their
group of businesses, and they should act more like coaches
than bosses.
My job was to select the best people to run those businesses
and those groups, let them do it, coach them so they learn
even faster, and assure we have a strong internal check and
balance audit process that verifies that they are adhering
to the principles and the policies that we've agreed upon.
People at the top should, above all, be leaders; quite
often, they act like managers.
Managers administer; leaders innovate.
Managers rely on systems; leaders rely on people.
Managers need control; leaders rely on trust.
Managers work on getting things right; leaders work on the
right things.
At Wells Fargo, we believe personal leadership is the key to
success.
We believe the answer to every problem, issue, or
opportunity in our company is already known by some person
or team in the company.
The leader only has to find that person, listen, and help
effect the change.
By the way, the people with the best answers are not always
the people with the most stripes.
True leaders do not demand loyalty, they create it.
They use conflict among diverse points of view to enable the
team to reach new insights.
They exert influence by reinforcing values.
At Wells Fargo, we manage these hundred different
businesses, spanning a wide geography across all of North
America and internationally, by sharing a corporate culture
that people believe in and align with, not by command and
control or hierarchy.
A good leader inspires a team to have confidence in him or
her; a great leader inspires a team to have confidence in
themselves.
This may surprise you.
At Wells Fargo, our most important constituent is not our
customers; it's our people.
Because our people have the greatest influence on our
customers and how our customers perceive Wells Fargo.
Our people influence the attitude of our customers more than
anything else.
Our people are key to customer satisfaction and increasing
market share.
So, my job as CEO of the past 15 years was really quite
simple:
Cause the organization to focus on customers.
Recognize that the key to consistent bottom line growth is
actually the top line: revenue growth.
Hire, retain, reward, and recognize the best people.
Coach them to be effective leaders.
Make sure they care.
In selecting people, I don't care how much a person knows
until I know how much they care.
Give people the responsibility, an accounted way to run
their own business.
Encourage them to be active in their communities, to be
leaders in their communities.
Create, describe, and communicate the corporate culture, its
vision and values.
Make sure everyone is having some fun.
Then, just get out of their way and cheer, as they achieve
consistent, record-breaking, industry-leading results.
In short, what I learned on the athletic fields and from 40-
plus years in the business world is that, success is all
about people, especially in financial services or other
service businesses.
At Wells Fargo, we call it, "People as a competitive
advantage.?
Few, if any, of other large financial institutions really
walk that talk.
Our emphasis on people is the foundation of our company's
culture, our growth, and our success.
Because we are so decentralized, and rely for results on
individual business leaders ? which number in the thousands
by the way ? we manage the overall company by culture,
shared vision, and values, and coaching.
Incidentally, I don't remember these concepts ever being
presented, let alone taught, when I was at the Stanford
Business School.
So, what I would now like to do is, give you some examples
of how culture influences our behavior and decision-making
process.
I believe these examples apply to all businesses, but again,
in particular, those that have a direct service relationship
with their customers.
Take acquisition strategy, for example.
At Wells Fargo, we will only do those acquisitions where the
company that we are considering acquiring has a culture that
is similar to Wells Fargo's.
Our culture is described in this "Vision and Values" booklet
that is updated about every two years and was first
published about twenty years ago.
It describes in great detail our vision, values, culture,
and operating philosophy.
If any one of you is interested in a copy of this, I have a
few of them here.
So, early on in the discussion stage of a possible
acquisition, we will give the principals this booklet and
ask them to compare their culture to ours.
We ask them to estimate how well such a vision and values
will be accepted.
If the cultures are considered to be incompatible, we would
terminate further discussions.
A prime example of the role of culture in our acquisition
decision-making process was when other large banks were
buying investment banks in the late 1990's; we did not.
We felt that the investment banking culture was incompatible
with ours.
We are a relationship-focused company; investment banks are
often transactionally-focused.
We are a team-focused company with team incentives.
Investment banks are often made up of independent-minded,
highly-paid stars, who are individually-incented.
Some investment banks often cross the line, in our belief,
in terms of ethical behavior, and often take excessive risk
relative to rewards.
We predicted that six out of ten of these investment bank
acquisitions by commercial banks would not work.
We were wrong.
Nine out of ten didn't work.
>>
[laughter]
In fact, that's how we missed the mess other large banks and
investment banks are in right now.
?Management by culture? told us that some of the actions
taken by others were morally and ethically wrong.
Other actions taken just did not make any risk / reward
sense to us.
Management by culture saved us.
But, things change.
Because of these culture and ethical lapses, the investment
banking industry has dramatically changed.
With the recent demise of Merrill Lynch, Lehman Brothers,
Bear Stearns and many smaller firms that actually left us in
the 1990's, there are only two broad, product line,
investment banks left, namely Goldman Sachs and Morgan
Stanley, and they are actually bank holding companies today.
We believe that this radical industry realignment has
permanently changed the competitive environment and business
practices, such that Wells Fargo can now be in the
investment banking business without compromising our culture
and values.
In combination with Wachovia, in just the past year, and
because of the investment banking expertise that Wachovia
had, we have gone from being a very small player to likely
ranking in the top ten of US investment banks this year, and
we think we?ll be in the top five within the next few years.
Our company's culture and belief in ?people as a competitive
advantage? also causes us to handle layoffs and staff
reductions different from others.
Now, we know it is often necessary, because of acquisitions
or other downsizing, that positions must be eliminated, but
eliminating positions does not necessarily mean that good,
loyal, experienced, and talented people need to be fired.
When our competitors do acquisitions, they can hardly wait
to tell The Street how many people will be fired and what
the cost savings will be.
We, in contrast, don't typically do acquisitions for cost
savings but rather for revenue growth.
Cost savings are usually a one-time profit gain.
Revenue growth is the gift that keeps on giving.
We do eliminate positions, but we attempt to find other jobs
for the people being displaced.
To find other jobs for the people being displaced, given the
turnover that exists in our company, there are nearly
thousands of positions available each year that can be
filled by people displaced by acquisitions and downsizing.
We call it "Retain and Retrain."
Since we believe in people as a competitive advantage, we
want to keep all the good, experienced people that we can on
our team.
Another area we differ from other banks was our early
commitment to, and continued belief that, we are a financial
services company much more than a bank.
For over two decades now, less than 50 percent of our
revenue comes from traditional banking.
Traditional banking is about a $500 billion industry.
The total financial services industry, which, in addition to
banking, includes insurance, investment banking, asset
management, mortgage, consumer finance, leasing, and other
products, is a $2.7 trillion in size, over five times larger
than banking.
The leading bank in a given state may have 20 percent to 30
percent banking share in that state.
It is hard to grow when you have such a large share.
However, this banking share leader would usually have less
than a five percent financial services market share in that
state.
That means there's plenty of room for growth if you are a
financial services company.
While others follow the advice of Wall Street, consulting
firms, and conventional business school teaching, being
strategically focused ie. a narrow product line, and some
were basically monolines, Wells Fargo has maintained a very
broad product line, delivering about every financial product
and service purchased by mass market and high-net-worth
consumers, as well as large, medium, and small businesses.
A lot of people, including some of my Stanford Business
School professors, think you shouldn't try to be all things
to all people.
Admittedly, it is hard to do, but if you can figure out how
to effectively deliver, through cross-selling, all the
financial products needed by all the potential customers in
your marketplace, there are enormous competitive advantages,
diversity of income streams, economics of scale and skill,
and compelling profitability.
Through my positions on Board of Directors and the number of
customer relationships that we have, I have helped to nudge
other companies to consider expanding their strategy and
selling more products to their existing customers and more
services, and it has also worked for them.
It has always fascinated me that a multi-product, financial
company like Wells Fargo was considered by some as almost a
conglomerate: too broad, not focused.
So I?d ask these people, "Is Wal-Mart a conglomerate?"
?No,? they would say.
?Are they focused??
?Absolutely. They are focused.?
?Well, what does Wal-Mart not sell??
I try to get people to understand that Wells Fargo is, first
and foremost, a distributor.
It's a distributor of commodity financial products.
Most all financial products are similar.
Thus, we have much more in common with other distributors of
commodity products, like Wal-Mart and Lowe's, than we did
with Goldman Sachs or Countrywide.
Just like Wal-Mart and Lowe's, our uniqueness is the way we
distribute those products, not the products themselves.
Consistent, organic, revenue growth through cross-selling is
probably Wells Fargo's most distinctive skill.
Our average retail household has 5.9 products and over one
in four has over eight products.
These are, by far, the highest cross-sell ratios in the
industry and about twice the industry average.
Our average wholesale customer has 6.4 products with us.
Our middle-market, commercial banking, division averages
close to ten products per customer.
Again, about double the industry average.
Organic, double-digit, revenue growth is essential for
consistent, double-digit, profit growth.
We have grown our revenue at a double-digit, compound rate
for 20 years, and therefore, we have had the profitability
and market share growth that I?ve already mentioned to you.
Since many of monolines have crashed and burned, or been
acquired, more companies now seem to be interested in cross-
selling and broadening their product line.
We have a 20 year head start on these Johnny-come-latelies,
and I'm glad we do.
Let me now mention the need for disciplined acquisitions.
This is required in any company in any industry.
I never understood the comment, "I know we paid a lot for
this deal, but it is a strategic acquisition.?
If you paid so much that you don't get a decent return, what
could be strategic about it?
A strategic deal should mean that it fits so well, you
should make a pile of money.
Let me ask you this about acquisition strategy.
If you believe, as I do, that practically all financial
segments ? and it?s true of many other industries ? are
cyclical, when during the cycle should you acquire? ? at the
top, or at the bottom?
When do most people buy?
I'm not going to ask you how many get that question right;
I'll leave that to your classroom.
Most people only want to buy great companies, and so do we;
but, of course, they pay high premiums.
Wells Fargo often buys fixer-uppers, companies who?ve had a
temporary set back, but still have good people and good
customers and a solid franchise.
We pay a lower price, because there is more work to do,
which will require more time and perhaps additional
investment.
But with our broad product line, our superior business
model, our strong, experienced management team, and our
cross-selling prowess, we can usually, within three years,
get the troubled company growing revenue at double digit
rates, just like the rest of our company.
A good example of this strategy, that Garth mentioned, was
the acquisition of Wachovia Bank last fall for $12.7
billion, a company whose market cap was over $90 billion a
couple years before that, and has the number one banking
market share in eight, fast-growing, southeastern states as
well as other great markets.
Yes, we have some problems to fix, but I believe this will
turn out to be the best and most profitable acquisition in
banking history and among the best in all of corporate
history.
We also often buy smaller companies rather than larger
companies, because their culture is more similar to ours,
the implementation risks are less, and so is the risk of
being wrong.
Most of our large bank competitors buy only large companies.
When we do a deal, the financial projections must clear two
hurdles: a minimum 15 percent internal rate of return and
accreted to existing stockholders by no later than year
three.
Both are important.
If you have a PE ratio higher than your acquisition target,
it is relatively easy to be accreted, but there is usually a
reason for the PE difference: the target has probably been
growing at a slower rate.
If you give the sellers most of your PE difference, you will
soon grow more slowly as well.
Your PE will fall.
Requiring both an IRR and an accretive ____ rate, ensures
you only do deals that will add value no matter how you
elect to pay for them: stock, cash, or the combination of
both.
Most companies don't do that.
Some companies set their IRR hurdle rate too low, in my
opinion, at their so-called ?cost of capital,? something
they probably learned in business school as I did.
Who wants to earn only their cost of capital?
That's just sure step toward mediocrity.
Others think any acquisition that is accretive is good,
without considering the inherent PE differences.
Let me ask you this question.
Should you take actions based upon the advice of so-called
industry visionaries, pundits, the media, and Wall Street
experts?
When I first started running major bank businesses in the
late 1970s, I was told by my boss that branches were dead
and paper checks were history; we should start reducing both
immediately.
Well, there are more branches today than there have ever
been, and they increase every year.
Only in the past couple years, 35 years later, are we seeing
paper checks decline.
In the 1980s, I was told that the mortgage business is a
lousy business and we should get out of it.
In the early 1990's I was told that banking margins were
falling so rapidly, and non-banking competitors were growing
market share so fast, that banking was all about cutting
cost.
The cost cutters would ultimately win.
In the late 1990's, I was told that the Internet would make
branches obsolete.
Bill Gates said banks were dinosaurs.
By the early 2000s, everything was reversed.
It was now all about revenue growth, not cost cutting.
I was also told branches were now so valuable, we should
open them by the thousands.
As we know, those visionaries were consistently wrong.
Ladies and gentlemen, it is important to listen to the
futurists, the pundits, the media, and Wall Street, because
there is usually some rationale to their positions, but in
my opinion, don't do anything until you see signs that
customers are actually voting with their feet.
Look for the earliest possible signs of radical change.
If you don't see any, stay away from the bleeding edge.
Customers, I said, use their feet.
Don't look at eyeballs as a reason for market evaluations.
Contrary to the industry, we've been opening new stores and
acquiring stores through acquisitions at the same pace
practically for two decades, and we are continuing to do so.
We never stopped or restarted, and we?ve always focused on
revenue over cost cutting
We also developed what is now considered the best,
integrated Internet banking channel in the industry, and it
serves all of our customer?s personal, business, and
investment needs through one single sign-on, whether that
person enters for their own personal accounts, their
business accounts, or their wealth management accounts.
Customers can navigate from one to the other easily and
efficiently.
Global Finance Magazine just rated our Internet offering as
the best in the world.
During the Internet glory days, unlike the pundits and
consulting companies and many of our competitors, we never
saw the Internet as a competing channel.
We saw it as complementing our other distribution channels.
And the vast majority of all of our customers are actually
multiple-channel users.
They use our stores, the Internet, the ATMs, and the
telephone.
We never saw, nor expected customers to suddenly stop using
their primary channel and immediately go exclusively to a
new channel.
We believed that if they did begin to shift, they would
shift gradually, and in such a moderate pace, that we could
reconfigure our distribution network accordingly.
Many of our competitors, during the Internet craze, closed
their branches in anticipation of a major change in customer
behavior, and then reversed all of that a few years later.
Let me now mention Scale vs. Skill.
How many times do you hear a CEO say, ?I need to get bigger
to be better??
I don't buy that.
You get bigger by being better; you don't get better by
being bigger.
Scale is certainly important in some business, but is often
overrated.
For example, in banking, I would say over a hundred billion
dollars in assets or so, skill is much more important than
scale.
Skill is finding the best way to do something in one place,
say a store or with a customer, and then replicating that
over your entire network.
That's the only advantage, to me, of being big.
You get to take a good idea and multiply it thousands of
times vs. maybe less than a hundred times for a smaller
company.
Otherwise, size can be a deterrent to organic growth.
Why?
Because you often lose touch with your customers and team
members.
Bureaucracy sets in, hierarchy rules, you lose speed to
market and fast decision-making.
How about risk management?
Well, you can't be considered the best financial services
company in the industry unless you're the best at managing
risk, risk of all forms: credit risk, interest rate risk,
and operational risk.
All segments of the financial services industry are
cyclical, and it's quite common that towards the end of the
positive side of the cycle, asset values get elevated and
risk spreads decline, to a level beyond ? and in some cases
far beyond ? their fundamental levels.
Only if you are disciplined, diversified, and have skilled
and experienced managers and leaders that have reduced your
exposure to such overvaluations, can you avoid the
writedowns, as these assets are eventually valued
significantly lower.
You only have to look at what happened in late 2007, when
the collapse of the subprime mortgage markets set off a re-
evaluation of all asset classes, and led to a rather
extended, credit crunch.
We bankers just don't get it.
Every decade or so, we have to relearn that covenants are
important, that risks do go up and down, but never
disappear, that the Greater Fool Theory, now known as
securitizations, collateral debt obligations, and the like,
do not last long, and that sooner, but most often later,
they will all come back to roost.
Wells Fargo, by the way, did not participate in this
charade.
Our responsible-lending values, that are included in our
vision and values booklet, saved us.
We did not offer any no-doc option, negative-amortization
loans, to subprime borrowers.
These exotic, subprime mortgage loans were not only
economically unsound, they were not appropriate for many
borrowers.
We lost 4% market share in our mortgage business for three
years between 2005 and 7, $160 billion in originations in
2006 alone.
In hindsight, we were glad we did.
For similar reasons, we also did not participate, to any
significant degree, in the latest Wall Street fads, such as
collateral debt obligations, structured investment vehicles
to hold assets off balance sheets, hedge funds financing,
off-balance-sheet conduits, low-covenant or no-covenant,
large, highly-leveraged loans.
We do not hold in our money market mutual funds, any
collateralized debt obligations, and commercial paper
obligations directly backed by subprime debt, and so on, and
so on.
Another area we seem to do things differently from others is
management succession in general, and CEO succession in
particular.
Years ago at Norwest, we put in the policy that all members
of the management committee, the top fifty or so people in
our company, had to retire not later than the end of the
year that they became 65.
Now, this was not done because we think people over 65
cannot continue to contribute to corporations.
It was done for succession-planning purposes.
It takes many years to prepare someone to take over senior
positions at a company the size and complexity of Wells
Fargo.
For senior positions, it may take three to five years; for
CEO position, even longer.
The ?65 and you?re out? policy was put in place to ensure
that everyone, including the board, knew there was a time
certain that someone would retire, and so plans could be
made to select the best candidates and give them the
necessary experience to handle the new job.
So, we ask all committee members to give us a minimum of two
years? notice.
And so, the ?65 and you?re out? policy is really something
more akin to a term limit.
It ensures there will be a well-timed process to select the
best placement, and the replacement candidate would also
know approximately when the position would be available.
It could be sooner, but it would not be later than that
date.
And that's how we handled CEO succession at Wells Fargo.
I don't think the old CEO should stay beyond 65 to play the
role of coach, as the new CEO is selected about 18 months to
two years before becoming CEO, and the old CEO becomes
chairman and helps coach the succession process.
I think the old CEO should give up his CEO role in that two
year period and remain a full-time chairman until his age of
65 expires.
Now, Wells Fargo followed this process with our CEO
succession, and in fact, that CEO succession started about
seven years before John Stump was selected in July of 2007.
By the way, I would have retired at the end of last year,
but because we acquired Wachovia, and because of the
financial crisis, I was asked to stay on for an extra year
to help integrate the acquisition and help with the crisis.
Let me conclude by asking you this question.
What is the most important metric in business?
If you had to pick only one metric to evaluate how well a
company is performing, and how likely it would perform in
the future, what would that be?
If I have learned anything over the past 40 years, it is
this: the key to the bottom line is actually the top line.
The only way to consistently grow profits is to consistently
grow organic risk-adjusted revenue.
If customers are giving you more of their business, as
evidenced by organic, revenue growth, you know you must be
doing a lot of things right.
You must have competitive products, you must have good
service, you must have good people who understand customer's
needs, you must be priced about right, your technology must
be competitive.
The opposite is also true.
If you?re not generating organic revenue, you have major
problems.
Cutting costs only lasts for so long, and will probably even
reduce future revenue.
Financial engineering is more often a long-term negative
than a positive.
If you believe that revenue is the key metric then, as CEO,
you must believe by example.
You must be customer-focused, call on customers, make sales?
calls with team members, and walk the talk.
I have probably made an average of two customer calls or
customer visits every day in my business career.
I don't ever remember that being considered important when I
was at the Stanford Business School.
Acquisitions that grow revenue after being acquired can
never be good investments for very long.
In my opinion, revenue growth is so important that you
shouldn't even make an acquisition unless the revenue growth
of the combined enterprise is higher than the sum of the
revenue growth of the two companies if they had remained
separate entities.
So, in my opinion, it's all about organic risk-adjusted
revenue growth year after year after year.
By the way, Wells Fargo has been growing revenue at double-
digit rates for 20 years, 12 percent annual compound rate,
for example.
So, it's indeed been quite a story and quite a journey.
It is really a story of the opportunity presented by
capitalism and the free enterprise system.
It's amazing what opportunities are out there.
Speaking of capitalism, I thought you'd like to know my
definition of capitalism and how it differs from other
political and economic systems.
It is particularly relevant, given what's going on in
Washington today.
First, Socialism.
That's when you have two cows, and the government gives one
to your neighbor.
Communism.
That's when you have two cows, you had to give both to the
government, and the government distributes half the milk to
the people and the other half spoils on the way to being
delivered
Fascism.
That's when you have two cows.
You have to give all the milk to the government officials.
The officials sell the milk and deposit the proceeds in
their Swiss bank account.
And then there's capitalism.
You have two cows.
You sell one of them, and you buy a bull.
>>
[laughter]
That's capitalism.
If I have learned anything in my 42 years of business, it is
this: Success, without fun, never lasts.
Fun without success isn't much fun.
My wish for all of you is to have both fun and success in
your business career.
Thank you for inviting me back to my roots.
I wish all of you the best in your career, and you have as
much fun as I?ve had in mine.
I'd now be happy to answer any questions you may have.
Thank you very much.
>>
[applause]
Q: Thank you for your talk.
I read a quote from Alan Greenspan nine months or so ago,
where he said if you were 50 years younger, he?d start a
bank.
I?m wondering if you agree with that sentiment, and if you
do, how that might apply to someone in our shoes that?s
going out into the working world.
A Well, I don't know about starting a bank, because it's a
difficult thing to do and takes time and a lot of capital
too, but I think it's financial services business ? might as
well change the word from bank branch ? is one of the great
industries in the world.
You know, money never declines.
It grows forever, and you're basically in the money business
if you?re in financial services.
And so, you have an industry that's always going up and
there's not many of that.
You know, you can have too much food, you can have too much
wine, but I don't know of anyone who has too much money.
>>
[laughter]
So, I think it's a great business.
Q You mentioned your business units were all very
decentralized.
How did you leverage, I guess, the integrated side of
things?
How did you manage your business units so they?re integrated
while being also decentralized?
A Yeah.
It's really our secret sauce.
We operate these decentralized businesses, but from a
customer standpoint, we hope to be viewed as one Wells
Fargo.
So, we partner between the businesses so that we can deliver
all the various products and services, that these
decentralized companies are manufacturing, as one, to the
customer.
It's a very difficult process.
It's kind of all explained in our vision and values but it
really ? you have to completely organize your company from
your technology to your incentive systems to your structure
to your reward and recognition system that encourages this
behavior.
And it's literally hundreds of small things that make that
happen.
And the way I explain this is, the bad news is, This is hard
to do.
The good news is, This is hard to do.
And it's a little bit like Wal-Mart.
Does anyone not know what Wal-Mart's strategy is?
Everyone knows it.
Low cost etc.
But it's how they do that strategy that nobody can
duplicate.
And it's a bit like ours.
Everyone sees the benefit of cross-selling now, but it's
very hard to do, so your competitive advantage is it's a
superior business model.
A superior business model that's easy doesn't stay superior
for long.
A bad business model that's hard is, of course, the worst
thing you can do.
>>
[laughter]
But a superior business model that's hard to do actually is
the upper right hand corner.
You can have a competitive advantage for a long time if it's
a superior business model and hard.
Q Just had a quick question.
You know, you said you had already bid for Wachovia.
There was a lot of coverage in the press, but what was the
process?
>> What process?
>> Like bidding for Wachovia when Citi had already done so.
And when the stock hit $7.80, or around that figure, did you
ever think that it was a bad move back in March?
>> Well, no, I guess, is the short answer.
You know it gets back to what I was trying to say before.
You know, the convention wisdom ? in my experience, if you
only had two choices to make, follow the conventional wisdom
or do the opposite.
If you did the opposite you would be better off.
I'm not saying you should do that, but I'm saying the
conventional wisdom is wrong, in my opinion, so much of the
time.
But again, you got to pay attention to it, because there's
usually some truth to it.
But you just have to have your own conviction.
Come to your own conclusion.
Do that quantitative analysis.
Listen to your people.
Forget ego.
Do the right thing, and usually, it will be opposite or
different from the conventional wisdom, and that's how you
do things.
Again, when do you buy?
You buy when things are great or when things are in trouble?
And when do people buy?
And this is not hard.
If you have a cyclical business, if you just buy it here and
perform on average, you're going to perform a lot better
than if you buy it up here.
It's cyclical.
Almost all businesses are cyclical.
So it's things like that.
So our market share and our acquisitions strategy has always
been greater by huge degree in the so-called bad times.
Q So you talk a lot about acquisitions and culture.
How would you characterize the difference between Wachovia's
culture and Wells Fargo's and what have you done to really
sort of done blend the two cultures together to have a
cohesive unit?
A The problem that happened with Wachovia is, they started
out as a regional bank and made a lot of acquisitions where
the theory was ? and the former CEO, ______, basically said,
?I?ve got to get bigger to be better.?
And that's, as I said earlier in my speech, that's very
dangerous.
And he bought things at very high prices, and got into
problems.
So then, they had to cut costs.
Then, he decided to go into brand new businesses because
they were fairly narrowly focused, saw the benefits or
diversity a little late, and thought they had to catch up.
And so, they went into investment banking.
They went into the mortgage business at the peak of the
cycle.
And so, what happened is, they had a lot of problems that
were caused by the failed implementation of a strategy, but
the fundamental businesses were actually quite strong.
They?re being masked by the mistakes they made, by going
into the investment banking and trading, by going into the
pick-a-pay in the savings business.
They way-overpaid for certain acquisitions, and had to make
that up by cost cutting and so on.
And we know what happened, and all we've done is sliced off
all the bad things ? we don't do the things that got them
into trouble.
We are paying part of the purchase price of the difference
between 90 billion and 12.7
is writing off all of the problems in their pick-a-pay
portfolio, but the underlying people are very culturally
similar, the businesses are very similar, and this will turn
out to be the best deal ever done in banking.
Q Thank you so much for joining us today.
My question is, you mentioned earlier that you have a very
keen focus on revenue growth and you also mentioned that you
guys are expanding your other business lines, such as
investment banking, but actually those two things in
combination, many people said over the last five years, are
precisely what led us into the crisis today, because retail
banks were focusing on growing the revenue, diversifying all
their risk on Wall Street, and that's kind of how we ended
up in the situation we had last year.
So, how do you feel as a bank, you guys can move forward
with those two things in mind and not face whatever the next
crisis may be?
A Well, as I said, I think the cultures that existed back
then we wouldn?t have gone into investment banking.
That has changed.
Now, when I talk about investment banking, I'm talking about
the meat and potatoes of investment banking, the
underwriting, debt and equity, and so on.
We did not do, and will not do the trading activities, the
CDOs, the structured products.
They didn't make any sense anyway.
So, but we couldn't even be in the basic part of the
investment banking, because of the cultures that exist, but
it's all gone now.
So, today, we think as I said, we were probably in the top
ten; now, we'll be in the top five.
Now, if that culture changes back to the old way, we will
just wind that business down if we can't compete.
I don't see that happening.
I think this is a fundamental change that's going to be
around, if not forever, for at least ten years.
And, if anything, I think the industry will move even closer
to a culture like Wells Fargo than it even is today, and one
reason that will occur is I think you're going to have close
watch by regulators in this industry for a long time.
Even if they wanted to, they're not going to be allowed to
do it, other than going into an unregulated hedge fund or
whatever, but it's not going to be done through investment
banking, in my opinion. We'll see.
Q I worked at Perella Weinberg, and was an adviser in the
Wachovia-Wells Fargo transaction, and you guys really have
something unique.
And you spoke about choosing people was your key role
I was just wondering if you could offer some advice as far
as, when you?re choosing people, what were the key
components or any advice related to that?
A Well, as I say, most of our senior people are home-grown.
We like to bring people in early in life, experience the
culture, see the most successful ones, and promote them,
etc.
Mostly, outside people we bring in are through acquisitions.
So again, we don't bring a lot of people in that get into
senior positions that haven't been with us for at least ten
years.
So it's kind of home grown is how we do that.
And we want people who have great values, who are smart but
do believe in teamwork, and really caring about customers
and their communities and so forth.
And we think that's more important, as I said, than brains
at the 99 percent level.
>>
[clapping]